yes it says all crypto I think because
we got in so early it was a really
really not particularly competitive
market so it was just us the market was
Tiny and we always thought this Market's
going to go somewhere welcome back to
another episode of the recruitment
mentors podcast I'm your host Tisha
mizzouz and on this week's episode I was
joined by the founders of plexus Sean
and zeh crypto is kind of mature there's
little pockets of Interest a lot of the
time it has Cycles in the same way that
traditional markets have Cycles except
the Cycles are infinitely more
aggressive it's now just over 30 of them
they've broken the four million GP Mark
and we really sat down and discussed how
they've gone about that what have been
the three biggest mistakes you guys have
made I think
um how they've cultivated their culture
how they've built their leadership team
and what the plans are for the future I
think the the short-term goal is to like
grow and grow in crypto I think for
anyone that has aspirations to scale
their recruitment business most of the
people that we have for interviews are
like pretty excited about the space
they're pretty interested in it like
some more so than others for anyone that
finds themselves always leveling out at
10 heads 15 heads 20 heads this is going
to be really insightful for you if you
really want to break past that barrier
and get to 30 plus enjoy the episode
Sean zeff welcome back to the podcast
yes hello a bit different it is this is
high level you've upped your game big
time obviously the same obviously why I
want to sit down with you guys there's a
few people that yeah really uh hopefully
at some point will be able to get sit
back down with I think people are always
curious about hearing people's stories
uh on the podcast and then then talking
about where they want to go and then
finding out if they actually got there
yeah and put you guys in that category
so obviously when we sat down uh it was
in your old Waterloo office
uh I think it's had a lot of meeting
room didn't we yeah it's a bad office
yeah that wasn't that bad it was right
it was all right I'll see you now in uh
I've been to an obviously office in
London Bridge which I think it's Mega
yeah but I know you're looking at
another office now we are
um so yeah just really excited to
ultimately unpack the last three years
so just to frame it up for everyone and
Sean if I get anything wrong tell me
okay
correct people so when we last sat down
which was uh April 2020.
um there was 13 of you in the business
um I think it was common towards the end
of your third year in business and and
the main goal that you had was to break
the million GP Mark which you did you
did 1.05 which we were just talking
about before this in your third year
business and then uh the financial year
just gone you ended uh on 4.6 uh GP 4.6
million uh GP so obviously over the last
three years that's what we've got up to
and there's just over uh 30 of you in
the business now uh and then again
Chrome if I'm wrong obviously the year
just gone you did around 90 pound 10
contract is that fair yep and then when
I was listening back to the podcast you
did way more contract before right yeah
what was the split then when we lost
that land you think because it was many
contracts I felt like yeah it was it was
it was probably about 60 40 to contract
really okay cool right so let's we'll
talk about that so purpose of this and
for everyone listening we're going to
talk about this journey which you've
gone on a lot of recruitment companies
that I speak to struggle to break the
the ceilings of 15 20 people get past
that it's a really difficult period and
you've been in the thick of this and I
know that you're trying to push this on
uh again now so that's what we're gonna
break down but I guess just to kick
start this sure I'm gonna come to you
first would love just to hear your take
because this might have changed or
evolved just with how the Market's being
the different people that we have in the
industry now or entering the industry
like what do you believe are the common
characteristics and traits that uh
successful recruiters uh possess in
today's market will have to possess in
today's market yeah so I think um when
we spoke last time I think I mentioned
that I think resilience is is always one
of the most important things like good
recruiters can have I think that's
evolved a little bit I think these days
like it's a combination of skill set and
mindset really and you know you can you
can try and train and develop both but I
guess mindset is probably more like
inherent somebody's personality a little
bit
um I think that's the two most important
things if you especially for us like we
try to combine that with market
knowledge that's a big thing for us
um I think if you can put those three
things together then you you should be a
pretty successful recruiter love that
that's what we're saying
uh similar to Sean I'd probably say like
uh like likability I think you know
you're in sales I think as a salesperson
I always say good sales people don't
sound like they're selling and half of
that I think is being likable and
trustworthy I think like the resilience
and the work ethic I think goes without
saying but I think if you're likable and
engaging and you'll come across as more
trustworthy and generally I think you'll
probably do better yeah so I think what
would also be useful for people then so
uh we were just talking a bit about what
both of you in terms of what you've
ended up focusing on what your
responsibilities have been between you I
think I'll just be useful framing for
people so again if I get in for this
wrong let me know but we put down it's a
zeph you found yourself over there I
don't know what period this is maybe the
last 12 months last six months I don't
know but for you you'll find yourself
more managing like being in more of like
a sales manager managing of the 360
function and very much more on the sales
floor right yeah no it's fair yeah I'm
sure there's other things you've done
but yeah and then Sean you you're the
Ops guy mate
not by choice no
so so let's just first like
who you either of you can share with me
but fair to say you guys committed to
the crypto space Have you continued to
commit to it over the last three years
because when I was listening back to the
podcast I think as if you were saying
like yeah we've we've always done this
but we like the idea of having different
pillars if that's Cloud if it's
architect or whatever so but I feel like
outside looking in uh when I think of
you guys I think you guys as one of the
sort of early people that really
committed to that blockchain crypto
space and as I'm sure you guys would be
more aware than me I think more and more
people have popped up right to focus on
that but over the last three years is it
fed say that most of your business or
all of your business you just focused on
that being your Niche yes it says all
crypto I think we realized that because
we got in so early it was a really
really like not particularly competitive
market so it was just us the market was
Tiny and we always thought this Market's
going to go somewhere but it's it has
Cycles in the same way traditional
markets have Cycles except the Cycles
are like infinitely more aggressive and
I think when we spoke to you last like
we were still in like a pretty heavy
bear market and there was like a lot
less than this bear market so I think if
you look at maybe market caps or crypto
I think back then it was maybe
three maybe two three hundred billion
now in in the pit of a bear markets 1.4
trillion so it's it's a huge Market it's
probably at the point where it's and I
don't want to curse and stuff but it's
probably too big to fail now and so it
doesn't make sense for us to like
spread ourselves so thin like we go all
in on crypto everyone does crypto and
then we can dominate the market we'll
have a larger market share because we
have so many people focusing on the same
goal and the same market and stuff so
we're all crypto I think longer term do
we look at maybe other brands possibly I
think that the short-term goal is to
like grow and grow in crypto and what
how would you describe the market
currently then the markets the markets
are I mean our crypto bear Market or
downturn started way before like the
traditional economy got hit and so it's
been uh probably
last May was probably when it started to
to drop and drop pretty aggressively
when it drops like a clients panic and
what does that actually look like in the
recruitment sense is that Seth we
planned on hiring not doing any of that
anymore yeah yeah what does that
actually look like it look it looks like
an absolutely rammed job sport just like
just etching off one off the other I
mean this like I mean don't do me wrong
this there's still plenty out there I
say I say to a lot of our guys I think
the crypto market is when it was crazy
it was super crazy and I think when it's
when it's like in a bear market like
this there's still jobs you just have to
like work harder to find them like it's
there's still very much a market and the
guys still do like quite a bit of
business and stuff so
you know I think a lot of people compare
it to traditional Tech markets but most
of our guys because they're graduates
have only ever worked in a crypto
recruitment job so they don't know what
it's like working in other markets and
what what's the current story then we're
telling people like oh like keep working
through this and there's it just goes
through Cycles or like there are still
success stories in a bear Market I mean
it's no it's no different from like a
traditional like tech company like there
would be people who are doing really
really well in the bear Market some of
my best years before plexus were in Bear
markets or bad markets in in Tech and so
you can just apply that same logic to to
crypto it's just more aggressive okay I
think what we found last time was like
2018-19 like that sort of bear Market
period it was like it was dead it was it
was pretty dead
um whereas now there's like within
because crypto is kind of mature there's
little pockets of Interest a lot of the
time so whilst overall it might be like
the market might have softened a little
bit there's there's little sort of
pockets of Interest around like
different layer twos that are popping up
or maybe like nfts are hot for a period
or stuff like that so if you're good
then you're still able to find like
little opportunities within that even in
like quite a maybe a slightly quieter
Market than it was before and then
either of you chip in on this but what
just because I think could be relevant
like how I think it could be really easy
for anyone in your business and anyone
that maybe you potentially interview
just to be really uh sucked into like
all the negativity like online the news
because I do feel like that's on like
steroids with crypto I feel like almost
just because I don't there's just so
much to it in terms of how many sort of
uh of like what everyone would call it
the olgar traditional infrastructure are
all still very much against it all like
there's just so much more to it whereas
I think if you're in a typical market
right now whether that be a tech Market
or just different markets there's still
some negativity but it's probably a bit
more easier to just focus on the things
that you can control and not let all of
that interest rate like your your
mindset how how have you gone about
protecting that for the guys or helping
people that because I feel like it yeah
they could just be full of negativity
all the time and just say yeah crypto's
Talent is done I don't know because I
feel like it's way more those people
generally don't apply to work for us
most of the people that we have in for
interviews are like pretty excited about
the space they're pretty interested in
it like some more so than others um but
you guys must be more on it though in
terms because I feel like I was I was I
always like to look at uh when I
interview people what they've been
posting online and stuff like that if
there's things that I can get them to
talk about but I think like Sean when I
was looking at your content like you're
always talking about just Market
commentary so I feel like with your
space you you've probably had to
continue to be probably an extra 25 30
more doing that with your team than
maybe if you was in like a typical
engineering Market I just feel I don't
know I might be wrong I don't know if
you've how you've communicated to the
team like this is what we're hearing
this is what's going on we've had to
really over communicate that because
they could all very easily go yeah that
we're done I think yeah it's I don't
know it's not really a challenge that
we've had yeah it is I mean so like I
that because people invest in crypto and
you can make money there's a lot of
people who are interested in it and so
naturally it gets a lot of clicks when
you post about it so there just is more
news about it like there isn't
mainstream news about I know you know
the new version of python or something
like that like people just aren't that
interested whereas if you've invested in
something you're interested so there's a
consonant like cycle of stuff that's
coming through and so when you work in
an office and there's like 30 people and
we're all working in the same sector
generally people talk about it anyway
and so it's not like you're in like just
this media Echo chamber where
everything's amazing and then oh my God
everything's tanking it's the worst and
stuff it's more just a you know it's
just it's just a market and we're all
talking about it and it just continues
to to roll irrespective of like really
really great news or really really bad
yeah okay nice so Sean let me come to
you on this end I want to know let's
just start with what have been the three
biggest mistakes you guys have made
since over the last three years
business-wise whatever like talk to us
what's been the three biggest mistakes I
think
um
God uh I I probably met so many it's
just so many there's so many people come
on I think I think
um and it's kind of annoying because we
kind of saw it happening through the
through the period there's a period and
and this is not just crypto this is like
the wide attack recruitment in general I
think like over the last couple of years
uh maybe up to sort of six nine months
ago like the market was super super boy
and and recruitment companies doing
really really well everybody's making
lots of money
um
I think our standards were slipping in
that period and it's really hard when
you like look at a sales team you know
you've got people who have only ever
known one market so they vote they've
only ever known good times they and they
come into that and it's like great
really easy to pull jobs like there's
loads of interest in the space easy to
easy to fill them great fees like this
is easy like no problem you know rocket
you know to work at nine o'clock in the
morning chip off at sort of half five
six and just you know and and just and
have a laugh and great Happy Days like
the recruitment that we knew as trainees
was like you're in early you're on the
tools it's hard you get a lot of
rejection you're working late and you
know and not everybody kind of makes it
but you know when it was as good as it
was it it breeds complacency and we knew
for a wheel like this is going to end
like some this is not going to last
forever you know like at some point the
Market's going to turn we've already
lived through like one crypto bear
Market we knew it was gonna you know
impact the hiring and stuff but like
it's so hard to like communicate that to
people that they just a lot of the time
they have to live it themselves
um so I think like yeah it's just trying
to like get people out of that sort of
complacency period you know and yeah
that was probably tough yeah I mean I'm
hearing that with so many people that
we're speaking to yeah I think it's it's
so it's so difficult to try and enforce
um certain standards when everyone's
doing deals and everyone's doing well
and it's been like you know why are you
on my back about this and it's just I
think me and him knew and we knew
probably for
maybe six nine months they're like it
like the standard just wasn't there the
the quality stuff we're doing just
wasn't there but it was just really hard
to like create change when everyone was
doing deals and everyone's making really
good money and stuff like that but it
doesn't surprise me with other people
yeah so anything obviously with with
these types of things there's always
learnings I guess you won't know until
you're in it but like because yeah I
think it'd be helpful for people would
you change how you tried to approach
getting on people's backs or could you
have communicated in a different way I
don't know is there anything that you
thought about that because I'm sure
you'll be like right we want to make
sure that we address this different next
time
that's difficult we did try to address
yeah
they're all just like guys
everything's fine really yeah so you
tried to attempt it to be like hey guys
being in the game long enough we know
this isn't the last yeah if we we need
to make sure that we keep the quality up
I know you're smashing deals you're
hitting your targets but we need to
really focus on quality and what they're
gonna well we're doing that I'm hitting
my target
so I think I think probably one thing
like we were pushing on performance
right and I think we generally always
been pretty good in terms of like having
a bit of an attitude of like this is
good but we can do better I think maybe
a little bit more around like wider
perception of like how our customers
perceive us as opposed to like just
internal performance like that's a good
Insight yeah like maybe like we we have
like an SLA with our clients where we
have a two-week turnaround so we
basically try and promote that we will
box your job off in five working days
and and we say to you if we'll commit
that to you you commit to doing all your
interviews in five working days and so
we could like I say to the guys almost
have like a conveyor belt mentality job
in boxed job off and then you just
manage like that that interview process
I think towards the end that slipped
because there was so much demand for
talent and such a short supply of talent
that clients were just jumping at like
candidates that weren't that great so
people were effectively being given a
pass on people who probably were not as
good as we should be sending and so I
think in hindsight maybe leaning more
around
how the clients and customers perceive
us and likewise the candidates as well
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a good
Insight I think that's something that
recruits should be doing more of getting
actual feedback from their customers
what what comes to mind if anything for
you then the second biggest mistake
second biggest mistake
um
that's a tough one uh like I think I
mean this is an obvious one but you know
we you go through phases where you where
you start hiring a lot of people and you
get into a Viewpoint in terms of the
sort of things that you're looking for
and those people maybe are good for
recruitment but they're not good for
recruitment app plexus and I think
knowing who you are as a company what it
is you're going to be asking people to
come in and do hiring based on your
values and your culture rather than just
can they do the job like are they are
they good for the job type stuff I think
that's probably a mistake that we made
but
maybe that wasn't more recent that was
quite a while back but that was
something we used to get part of the the
three years yeah looking at the last
three years yeah I think I think we
perhaps underestimated like the lead
time and the planning around some of the
non-sales highs I think when it comes to
hiring sales people we've been doing it
for you know quite a while a long time
and we're like we know what we're
looking for we know what works and what
doesn't work and we don't always get it
right but like I guess from a percentage
point of view we're like we're
relatively good at it like all the
hiring of like non-sales people so like
marketing talent and operations and
those sorts of things like it just takes
like so much longer to find the the
quality of people that that we want and
I think that's probably been a bit of a
learning why do you think that isn't is
it because you're not sure exactly
entirely on what you want or what good
looks like I think knowing what good
looks like a lot of the time is yeah um
is difficult like we like and you know
we brought in um an interim CMO to help
us out with the marketing stuff and like
and his view on like what what good
looks like from marketing is often you
know like different from from ours
obviously he's not right we're wrong
right he's the expert yeah yeah so
um yeah yeah so it's those types of
things can can often take a longer time
or you end up massively maybe yeah more
often getting it wrong in line with what
zeph was saying maybe they don't add to
the cultural in line with that so let's
talk about
um what a recruitment business looks
like when it's double the size it's
generating
um yeah a lot more uh Revenue Sean what
what does the actual infrastructure look
like or like what are you aiming for it
to look like because I know there's
still people that you're hiring for on
these things so because I know obviously
you guys have aspirations to continue to
scale and grow so it'd be good just to
hear your take on like how you sort of
visualize that how it currently looks so
what I'm asking is yeah what does the
leadership layer look like how many
managers have you got compared sales
people when you say the non-sales people
we're talking Ops we talk in marketing
internal talk to us a bit about how
you're trying to set up plexus or what
it looks like today and then also some
of the seats that you think are really
important to get to the the next stage
yeah so like where we were
um maybe like a year or yeah a year or
two ago is that hierarchy super flat me
and zeth still on the tools like still
managing day today still individually
training people and manage managing
sales people
um I'm sort of individually managing the
sort of Ops and finance and legal and
all that sort of stuff as well and
um it's I think when we we kind of had
this like period I guess like sort of
last summer last or summer last Autumn
time it was like right we we actually
need more of a hierarchy we need more
structure here like we can't
individually manage we can just about
individually manage a business of about
like 25 30 people but beyond that it's
going to be crazy trying to do that with
like 50 or 60 people so we've had to
like Implement like loads more structure
around uh around management for for
sales and on sales
um like our job now is I guess manage or
trying to manage
probably like seven or eight nine people
something like that I you know we don't
want to be individually like managing
every every single trainees and and I I
guess our view now is like how can we
how can we build to really scale like
really aggressively over the next year
or so how can we go from the current
sort of 30-year people that we are to 60
next year to 100 the year after that or
we have to put the structure in place to
do that now
um so what does that look like what does
that structure look like how are you
currently thinking about it
um I it's difficult to say from a
numbers point of view because we've
always especially for like for sales
people we we really really want to we've
hired a few seniors over the years but
we really want to hire organically and
train people up and get people in the
grads grad level and then and let them
develop organically into into management
because it gives the people
um you know the best opportunity to
progress in business
so but because of that there's obviously
a lead time on online
exactly right because you just need a
bit of it you need a bit of experience
um and we've got people that have been
doing it sort of you know two or three
years getting into that now
um for non-sales we've always been in
the view that we want to hire really
really high quality people we don't want
an enormous kind of back office team or
or anything like that so I I think we
probably want I guess
um five or six sort of really really
high quality sort of senior people who
are non-sales based
um and I'd include sort of l d and
Thailand
operations person yeah so like heads of
operation heads of marketing
um heads of talent heads of l d things
like that yeah so that would be like the
non-sales yeah and then how obviously
you said you implemented a hierarchy
hierarchy what does that actually look
like so I think you said to me what
you've got at the moment you've got what
free 360 managers and then one delivery
manager is that how it is yeah that's
how it is at the moment
um how are you thinking about that are
you thinking have you thought about
right we're only going to aim to have
five to six people to one manager or I
don't know how you're thinking about the
hierarchy of the actual sales team we're
thinking that we're going to hire a lot
of grads
um over the summer and there is a hell
of a lot of work for those guys to do
quite honestly like they're gonna
they're gonna be given a lot of
opportunity and they're great guys and
they're gonna rise to that hopefully I'm
sure they will
um and hopefully the people that are in
that kind of what we would call a kind
of senior level so like sort of 18
months two years hopefully those guys
over the next year or so will progress
to a point where we can sort of start
looking at them for sort of Junior
management roles I think like that that
billing management phase is is probably
one of the hardest things you can do in
recruitment like I know certainly in my
sort of first probably like you know
year or so at that level years and years
ago like I definitely struggled it's
really really hard so we really want to
support those guys as much as possible
not like you know completely wrapping in
Cotton wool but like it's like give them
an enough sort of support and help and
stuff so you know they can um they can
develop and get better without it being
completely overwhelming for them I think
you can probably sales manage up to I
guess directly maybe sort of eight ten
people I think beyond that is going to
be it's going to be like pretty
challenging and you're going to struggle
to do your own business on top of that
so and what's top of mind to obviously
these people were clearly absolutely
fundamental and important to uh growing
your business and getting to this girl
you want to
I've lost count of the amount of
recruitment owners that I've spoken to
that know who those people are but
oftentimes leave
so what have we yeah what how are we
thinking about making sure those people
that are clearly fundamental to your uh
plans are thinking about retaining them
making sure that they don't end up in a
position where they've got more stress
they're earning less money about how
you're thinking about that because
that's probably just as important
yeah I mean I think just communication
with them like just find out like
regularly checking in with them like
where where are you at how you finding
things and making sure that they have a
route to earning more money year on year
if money's like the key drive for them
for a lot of them it might be like
opportunities like going and opening
another office but making sure that road
map's clear to them and if they're
unhappy I think Sean and I are generally
pretty good at like saying to people
just tell us what you're thinking like
if there's an issue I'm not guaranteeing
I can solve it but it's better that you
communicate so at least we both know
sort of where we stand with stuff so I
think as long as people feel like
they're heard and they can affect change
I think that's a frustration for a lot
of people it's earnings but it's also am
I able to affect change in my own
environment and if they can't they're
like well I'll just go to a new
environment and I said that's that's
interesting so what what do what do you
um what do you think were some of the
like as I said to you at the start of
this a lot of people struggle to get to
where you guys are now
what were some of the biggest barriers
or things that you've already mentioned
that uh getting some of the non-sales
people took longer than you anticipated
was there any other barriers that you
found just took a bit longer to get over
the new anticipated maybe on the sell
side or I don't know is there anything
else that I think one thing I think that
and this maybe goes back to a mistake
actually that we made I don't think or I
think it took us too long to empower
other people in the company to step up
into these roles that they're now
assuming and a lot of the time they
would wait for like guidance for us
rather than us empowering them to make
the calls on stuff that they probably
already knew how we would react to stuff
and so that was probably something that
we didn't do that we're now super hot on
in terms of making sure that these
people feel comfortable owning certain
components of like the job whether it be
like a culture or standards or doing
some training and stuff like that I
think we're much better now at
empowering people to do that and was
that because it was just a very flat and
you had just become accustomed to doing
things and saying yeah we do this or we
do that how we do that I I think it's
like on us as like with a lot of these
sort of things I think we didn't
communicate it to them and so they just
assumed that it wasn't you know for them
to do that or they didn't maybe want to
um like go above their their station or
anything like that so when Sean was
talking about it it was a less of a flat
structure so it was basically just Sean
and I manage loads of people we're now
trying to empower more people to step up
and those people who are in those
management roles are now in a position
where they're starting to get people
that are
hopefully progressing into management so
they will effectively be moving into
managing managers at some point and so
that's how you can make it a bit more
scalable so which one said you can you
know effectively manage 10 people you
can manage more people but not directly
because then you'll have seniors
printable stuff within your team that
are then taking ownership of other
members of that effective cost cost
center yeah and was it difficult because
I speak to a lot of uh recruitment
companies who are at that stage and
they'd probably describe themselves like
you did in terms of we're on the tools
or in the business we're doing all that
how did like was that a difficult period
for a review obviously it's effort
sounds like you're a bit more still in
that leading by the front you're you're
managing managers or helping inspire
leaders of these settings but did either
of you find it difficult to stop being
that the the person who's on the tools
who's doing deals like was that a
difficult period or did you find that
hard to do
um I think we all when when we set up we
always wanted to like try and leave from
the front a little bit to set standards
um and I I think that there's there's
definitely a lot of recruit managers
I've seen over the years who have
probably got off the tools a little bit
too early there's probably a there's
probably an equal share of people that
have been on the tools too long so
finding that like that that sort of
sweet spot is is quite tricky
um
yeah I don't know I mean I I has does
anyone ever nail it I don't know how did
you approach it was you like right did
you like did you just start handing over
clients did you just slowly but yeah how
did you actually I think every time like
and most clients will I I get sometimes
you'll have clients for years and years
and years and years and years and you
hope so but like over time some clients
will sort of fade out so I guess it's
just around like the levels of BD that
we don't means I haven't done any BD for
years like two or three years like a lot
of it is just sort of existing
relationships and stuff
um but I guess now we're starting to
pass newer stuff over or even some of
the existing stuff over as well just
because from a time management
perspective we just don't have the
capacity to to kind of do it I think
we've set we've set a bar of
um of Standards which is like hopefully
quite good and hopefully something for
people to Aspire to I think that's
that's enough
um I don't think you need to do it
absolutely every single year and I think
actually if we if we were to continue to
try and do it every single year it would
probably detract from what else we were
doing you know we we spent especially
when the market was good like we spent a
lot of time just working in the business
you know like the delivery guys were
working you know quite heavily for us
and you know there was a lot of business
to be done that was great but like
the flip side of that is you know how
much time did we think about like what's
going on in people's heads you know like
speaking to other managers like working
on the business you know how are people
really feeling is everyone happy because
they're just doing loads of deals or are
there frustrations you know is there
sort of stuff like under the surface and
there were that we probably missed a
little bit because we were kind of you
know in it too much and I think just in
terms of like the mechanics because I
think I would have liked to have
understood this better if I was three
years ago I think basically the way that
we did it and we made like errors along
the way was to to sort of phase it so
like at the start it was obviously when
we were doing the billing management
role effectively we were doing bde we
were sourcing our own candidates we then
started moving to a point where we only
did like the BD and managing the client
relationships and then to the point
where we just didn't do BD and we just
worked with with clients we already had
and that way it was sort of like it was
a phased like a phased like lifting of
responsibilities and that slowly fed
more time into being on the business
than in the business yeah that's helpful
and did you like communicate to people
that's what you were doing yeah yeah
like I I was I was pretty early on in
terms of like working with delivery guys
and then trying to upskill them in terms
of rather than just doing a sourcing
accountants and managing the candidate
profile doing some like account
management and stuff and like they would
come to me with oh well I don't know
what to do with this I'm like I'll go
back speak to the client say you would
frame it and then they would do it and
then they get more comfortable doing it
and then they're able to help upskill
other people and so they can do a true
270 role then this podcast is proudly
partnered with vincere the all-in-one
recruitment agency software that over 20
000 recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning one-up
sales sales and motivation platform that
enables you to maximize the potential of
your teams we love partnering with both
of these organizations because they
share our mission in helping you get the
most out of your people and your
business you can get exclusive offers
because you listen to this podcast and
get up to 10 of the usage price forever
use the link in the show notes to get
your hands on that let's get back to the
episode how curious how uh because when
I was listening back to our last
conversation I sort of described uh you
guys having a team of delivery
Consultants something that I didn't hear
a whole lot of but I'd say that's become
it super super popular particularly when
obviously it was absolutely crazy how
fundamental has the delivery team been
for you to get to where you are now do
you think yeah super important like I've
always said it's like our like the
engine room as in like the the when when
the delivery team's firing it frees up
the 360 guys just to sort of focus on
their own marketing so all the other
stuff that they're generating on the
side should get picked up by delivering
I think the upskilling of a delivery
team makes an enormous difference to the
quality of service you're able to give
your clients because you're able to
like stick to that five-day turnaround
on CVS and there are multiple points of
contacts for clients so if someone's on
holiday they already they're already
dealing with the delivery consultant so
there's two points of contacts and stuff
for someone to reach out to so I think
it's super important sounds quite key
let's break this down a bit because I
think this would be helpful for people
because
like I don't know how you're thinking
about it it's clearly being part of your
business plan like throughout um the
majority of the time but I think
particularly for uh recruitment
companies that are smaller when I've
spoken to them over the last like three
to six months the idea of having people
in the business that aren't capable
capable of winning their own clients
is just something that uh they don't
feel overly great about and I think
every person I spoke to recently
recruiter wise who maybe has been I
don't know let go or if I'm speaking to
a rhetoric and I'm saying how how are
you finding the market emotional
criminal owners are going yeah we want
people who have 360 experience so like
it'd be good just to because you you've
done it for a lot of time clearly
learned a lot so just firstly so what is
the actual split in your company right
now in terms of like the um the 360 team
to deliver a team like what how many
people in the free six in the 360 team
compared to the delivery team it's
probably a third about that about a
third this is something we battle with
on a weekly basis what's that this the
ratio of like how many delivery people
you have how many 360. what's the
current ratio then it's about third
delivery Tuesday's 360. so out of your
entire like consultant sales force
whatever you call it to one third of
them is delivery about that yeah and
then how so just and then how do you
sell it up and your questions on like
maybe if you were to start a delivery
function tomorrow how you'd approach it
but like so how do they support the
entire
team yeah the other two pads yeah they
do so like a lot of the or the the
majority of the volume used to come from
Sean and I and a couple of the senior
guys whereas now it's thrown open to
like pretty much any of the guys so we
delivery manager would effectively do a
delivery meet with his team just to sort
of check in where are you at with your
your boxing off of this job and that job
and uh he would then speak to previously
would have been Sean and I right around
like coordinating what what the next
wave of jobs looks like but these days
Sean life tried to step back from that
and said reach out to the individual
managers of the 360 guys directly and
find out you know what's the job flow
like on their team so it now runs
autonomously without us okay we were
super involved in it so let's just talk
about uh this for a for a second then so
um like I guess let me just start like
if like knowing what you know now if you
were to uh start a delivery function
from scratch tomorrow what would the
first 90 days look like
okay so like you it's similar business
model to us in terms of hiring just
training just like yeah like just
because I think uh this is something I
think often growing recruitment
companies think about but then they're
worried about are we going to have these
people on quite High bases that aren't
capable winning business I don't know
yeah I think there's there's things that
a lot of people concerned or worried
about okay so I I would get somebody who
was your strongest person at delivering
roles right so if you evaluate your
whole business who's the person that you
know does a great job of like account
managing and runs a super tight ship
like super tight process in terms of
delivering against jobs that person
could in theory effectively head up that
function okay when you're hiring grads
those grads would then go into that
function and this person would teach
them the process but that process needs
to be tight like we used to have we used
to absolutely rinse meal time because I
used to have like sheets for everything
I'm like look this is this is the
process follow this process make it
simple like so that people can follow
when they're new to the job that person
will effectively upskill
as in the process for when I give you a
job this is what you do yeah post it on
link yeah yeah do this all right the
actual process of step by step what you
do to Source yeah yeah so like and
ideally you don't even have to get
through like you get the job covered off
without having to go through like
looking at GitHub Forks yeah yeah
like that just like go on the database
yeah it's actually this okay cool yeah
yeah so they would affect it before that
process that person would be effectively
the manager of that function and would
teach new people effectively trainees
whether it be grads or whatever and and
generally these people I I it's not
always the case but the people who we've
always found have done really well uh
um delivery are those people who who
take pride in like attention to detail
and have a nice process and they're like
they're like structure and stuff like
that and generally those sort of people
do quite well so when you're hiring
stuff we would often start interviewing
and saying I think that person is really
well suited to delivery because they
seem to have that more sort of delivery
mindset so I would try and start
thinking about that
when there's people then join they
obviously join that that delivery
manager that manager would basically be
making sure that they were working at
the same sort of standard as as you were
and just start drip feeding jobs in
right over time particularly if you've
got like a sales guy who's like super
super good at like generating jobs you
know you have that that that sales
person who just hates doing delivery
they hate sourcing profiles if but
they're really good at generating jobs
just let them do that and get some like
delivery people just to start working
those jobs in the background it then
just becomes scalable from there because
the more people that understand the
process the easier the easier other
people will learn it just through
osmosis proximity learning just being
around those people okay cool right
couple questions then firstly like I
know it'll evolve over time but how
involved are they in the process that
they Source it qualify the candidate
then hand it over to do the
qualification interview prep like what
does that look like yeah so I think like
when they first start it's very much
just a 90 degree yeah so you basically
just maybe Source candidates and stuff
those accountants would then go over to
360 person that three six person would
probably still qualify that candidate
and then manage that process when they
probably get to consultant now they're
doing a full 180 job so Theory no one
talks to like oh there are three six
bedroom talks to the candidates and they
will still be involved in some of the
client stuff but maybe not the more
difficult stuff when they go to like
senior principal level they're probably
at the level there where they can take
specs and like effectively run a whole
process outside of the initial
generation they don't agree in terms
yeah they wouldn't be a client on yeah
they would take an intake call do all
that and then close candidates yeah all
of that okay cool and then what does a
what does a good look like what are the
some of the key metrics that you measure
people against quite early on there's
again are you looking at I don't know
um CV to interview ratios like what are
the sort of key metrics so we push uh
delivery on 10 CVS to clients like per
week okay so the CVS will go to the 360
console and they will either say yeah
they're good or no they're not but I
think we push him on 10 CVS per week the
thought prices behind that is if they're
doing 10 CVS
per week they're working two jobs per
week the SLA says five days but we try
and Target the guy to do it in two and a
half or they know that maybe it rolls on
they work two at the same time morning
and afternoon to break it up a bit and
that would be 40 CVS per month interior
they work eight jobs if they work eight
jobs they're probably going to be
placing about three to four of them per
month okay uh talk to me about and then
I know what people will think oh wait I
think you've broken that down really
well thank you for sharing that
commission what are we saying how have
you structured that it might have
evolved over time
how have you because typically I've
found that when I speak to people the
360 commission is better than the
delivery commission how have you done
that because they're not bringing on the
client and how have you approach that um
so it's very topical actually yeah it is
we just changed we're just not
unchanging our lit Sean go through that
if you want
um so we originally we had a sort of
flat fee structure which wraps so when's
that's talking about like the
consultants in your consultant principal
consultant thing like basically the more
responsibility they have in as a
delivery person the higher commission
they get per placement
um we had a lot of feedback over
um I guess like last summer and stuff
around like some of the um delivery
people who are maybe um a bit unhappy
and it's a bit of a weird one because
actually like you know these are people
that have probably been in recruitment
for like a year or two or something like
that and they're earning reasonable
money you know they're earning sort of
like 40 50 60k sometimes stuff like that
and you know which
at the the time they came in for
interview they probably would have been
pretty happy with but the problem is
that there was a huge discrepancy
between the delivery guys and the 360
guys and you know we had 360 guys who
were in a handful of or a fair few of
them who have only been recruitment for
you know like a couple of years two
three years earning sort of you know 150
200 Grand a year and because there's
such a a difference between the two
teams that was basically just like just
pissing them off a little bit quite
frankly so so we did a big like deep
dive into it and
um and and change the model a little bit
to bring the two commissions
um a bit more in line basically split
the value of the deals what we found our
deal values average deal values have
gone up
um just consistently really over the
years and you know when when we
originally designed the initial
commission structure you know it was it
was it was pretty good it was pretty
fair to to the delivery guys it was a
flat fee yeah but and and you could you
know you can roughly work out as a
percentage but it was it was with an
annual bonus as well yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um what we see what we've seen is that
the the guys have um we've been able to
do some really really good high value
business
um which is great but obviously with
flat fee commission and the delivery
guys weren't seeing the upside on those
deals so it had to change
um so if you change it to a percentage
Yeah
percentage but like so what is that have
you done it so then what they get an
agree percentage of the overall annual
salary basically yeah so you just split
the fee so say the fee is like you know
30 grand or whatever then you know maybe
um you know 20 30 whatever something
like that might go to the delivery
person
um and then the rest of it will be
allocated towards a 360 person and then
that goes through our commission scheme
right okay yeah so like you I'll get
what you mean so there's basically
you've just split the pot basically
exactly yeah so like based on the fee
some percentage goes delivery the rest
go to sort of 360. and on the average
deal sizes it was it's probably about
the same as what it was before but for
the larger Deals they get actually they
get the rewarded they get the upside
plus they'll get the upside on the
multiple deals as well so that the the
over performers the overachievers will
be more heavily rewarded just like they
would be on 360 because that wasn't
really happening quite as much so yeah
they're they're also incentivized as
well and the same with the 360 guys are
too
um like bundle starters so like to to
encourage like consistency obviously the
more stars you can have in a month the
higher up the commission band Yes
whereas before it was just flat so it
doesn't make any difference whether they
had like an absolute knockout quarter
and then did nothing yeah quarter how um
uh how how fundamental is the delivery
function going to be to you getting to
60 heads
yeah I think as as important as it's
always been I think that the split of
you know our Peak a couple of years ago
we were 50 50 delivery in 360. which I
think you know and for most people now
the most directors have probably
listened to that and be like and think
that's probably super high but at the
time it was operating like really really
well
um but when especially when you get
people that are at what for that to work
you need people to pull a lot of jobs
obviously right so but as means I have
to sort of come away from the tools a
little bit and and the market sort of
softened a little bit then you know that
balance has to probably be redressed a
little bit so which we've already done
um it will still be a crucial component
to the business but I guess like
yeah developing
like most people you said you were
talking to they only want people that
can that can bring fees in I think for
us we we probably want most people to be
able to do that but there's still a
place for people who aren't always well
that's not naturally going to suit them
as well I think this is one of the
reasons why we why it's been successful
is that there's there's a home for those
people you know maybe they don't want to
go out there and do like the proper sort
of Hardcore BD stuff and and everything
else some people love that some people
don't but for the people that don't then
okay like is there still a role for them
can they still be successful at plexus
and like have a good career and stuff
and like yeah they can you know so you
know that's the the upside isn't it
because if you don't have something like
that and you're like I absolutely hate
BD ROM to it yeah you then you
yeah you're a failure or there's nowhere
else for you to go it works the other
way around as well right because you get
you and like I said you need people that
are BD machines for sure and and you
know probably the best recruiters do
fall into that category the best 360
recruiters so and you want to be able to
support that because probably you those
guys they don't really want to do loads
and loads and loads of delivery actually
it's going to like eat into their time
loads you know they go and pull 10 jobs
and they're like all right so let's just
talk about that then because again
clearly this is fundamental to you guys
scaling and how you've got to this point
and less on the flip side then when we
say 360 obviously typically people would
perceive that that they manage the whole
process right but what it sounds like is
they're mainly focused on just pulling
jobs the sales side so what what are the
expectations of these people who have a
massive powerful resource in this
delivery team what the what are your
expectations of them is it just are
there mainly just focusing on yeah
Market mapping building their patch
um bringing on a jobs whatever like what
are the expectations of the people that
aren't in the delivery function then
because you're calling them 360 but it
doesn't sound like they are yeah it's a
good question I mean 360 should be able
to do 360 obviously like as as the name
implies but yeah I guess the reality is
that
certainly for the people that are higher
up that so we want the I guess some of
the most important people that we want
to support at the moment is that kind of
middle management team right so if
you're if you're an early stage like
billing manager you've been in job for
like two three four years you're
learning the ropes you're probably
managing like two three four people
something like that what you're going to
find is that your biggest challenge is
time management yeah so to be able to
support that then we try and give those
guys the the more experienced delivery
people and the most access to those
delivery people to free up their time a
little bit so those guys probably are I
guess they'll probably fall more into
that like BD Camp they'll probably be
offloading a higher percentage of their
jobs the more trainee 360 people will
probably be working more of those jobs
and certainly with the jobs within their
own patch we don't like
super strictly lock people into sort of
certain patches but we do we do suggest
and ask them to focus on sort of certain
areas so some people might do like front
end or they might do ux or whatever and
really for jobs in their in their patch
they should definitely definitely be
working their own jobs really on 360 up
to you know sort of management level
stuff outside of their patch maybe
there's more of an argument to pass
those jobs over to delivery so that it
doesn't detract from you know they're
going off and speaking to different
types of people and and that sort of
soaking up their time that's really
interesting actually that makes sense
because they're absolutely fundamental
for you guys to grow
they're often the people that are the
most time poor as the as you're putting
more people underneath them so obviously
one of the so if I'm in that sea
obviously and I speak to these people
all the time the highest leverage one of
the highest leverage activities they can
do besides coaching their team and
helping their team is winning business
and that could be for their team to work
on all the time but what you're doing is
uh helping these people
um yeah by giving them make sure they've
got a really good resource and support
from the delivery function so they can
still do that and then there's a very
high chance that they're still going to
be able to be making the money that they
were because they've got that resource
yeah and like when you talk earlier on
about like how are we supporting people
who are in that position because like I
guess most recruitment directors fear is
that that's a point they're going to
lose all their top performers and their
top business and all that sort of stuff
but I suppose for us why I'm not as
concerned with that is because they've
got an amazing opportunity it's super
supported by the delivery team they're
supported by us and everything else
they're spending time on like the sell
side and then they've got more time than
to coach to support the team because
they're they're leveraging the delivery
team yeah exactly that's that's super
interesting to be fair
um so what what's like is there anything
else then that's um top of mind going
into the this next phase then because
I'm sure you're thinking about it a lot
we've spoken a lot about I think you've
done a really good job of sharing some
of the things you double down on uh to
get to this point the delivery function
have you approached growing the team
what what's really top of Mind we've
spoken about the non the non-billing
stuff and those seats but what else for
you guys now is really top of mind to
get to this this next phase so I think
it's creating the infrastructure and the
support structure for the business that
we have in five years so that is a lot
of the stuff around like the training
internal hiring marketing operations but
also Sales Management and so while we we
know that we're going to keep on hiring
and we are super conscious of the amount
of people that are sales managers are
going to have to try and manage and
stuff and so how do we how do we go
about supporting them is it that I don't
think it's necessarily A solution that
Sean and I go back to individually
managing sales managers but do we start
going to Market to try and find other
managers to try and support so there
isn't a big uh such a big time sponge
for these people also I think like
looking at the second wave of people
that we have in the business and and how
we can accelerate their route to
management as well the back office stuff
for the marketing stuff and the talent
stuff I think are stuff that we maybe
traditionally neglected or we've done it
but we haven't done it early enough and
so basically
building all of that stuff so that when
we are X number of people in the future
we have all of the the function ready to
support that um
obviously this is all stuff that you
wouldn't have a clue about Doom
recruitment
you know over here still don't yeah so
like how how are you approaching that
because like a lot of those things that
you just very much like I don't know
learning as you go asking for help
because you know you guys were top
performers great recruiters obviously
let's be honest up until a certain point
he was pretty much that but then leading
the team leading by the front managing a
lot of the stuff that you've probably
become comfortable with obviously Sean I
feel like you've got a bit more of the
short scrolled and things maybe more of
the things now your comfort zone on the
op side compared to zeph but all those
things you just said there it's like
proper business stuff in it it's not
doing deals and all that anymore
is it so how how are you approaching
that because there's a lot of things
that you're you're not going to be good
at to start with
I tell you what it is right this is like
I think we're generally both quite good
at just discussing this sort of stuff
and thinking does that make sense I
don't think it makes sense don't do it
or at the end it makes sense we'll do it
I think like
I think we're not the amount of times
like we've interviewed people that work
in these other areas particularly if I'm
interviewing an Ops person I'm sort of
just going in there like
cool what am I going to ask this person
I don't really know what's good I don't
really know what to ask him well
likewise like how do you interview a
marketing person when you're not a
marketer like you can ask them like you
know what are your blind spots what do
you think you're really good at what do
you think you're really bad at but like
is that a good answer I I don't know I
think like you have to just lean on
other people so like I think both of us
speak to a lot of external people like
mates of ours and ask them what they
think and how they're doing it like Sean
said we brought in a an interim CMO
because we knew we needed to get
marketing right because we want to try
and like because our Market is global we
need a global reach and well you can
have people like reaching out over the
phone it's not gonna be as strong as it
is digitally but you know we just don't
know what good looks like in a marketing
person yeah they seem sound they seem
like a cultural fit but are they a good
marketer so I think just reaching out to
people and just leaning on uh maybe
experts and other fields and just being
like yo help me out yeah I've got no
idea what I'm doing with this what do
you think I'm not gonna I think have you
not considered uh like an video
strategic advisor at this stage yeah we
have we have what's been the Vibes not
not really enjoying who you're speaking
to not no no no no we've spoken to some
like some super smart people like and
they they've sort of shared some some
really really good advice I think it's
like really hard to try and
find the right sort of NAD at the right
time for you and understand it what does
this person's value right now versus in
three years or what what are the
problems we're dealing with right now
and who solves those problems right now
because I think if you speak to any Ned
they'll love to say to you yeah I can
help you right now but actually
they're probably of more value
two years ago or there are more value
three years from now so just trying to
sort of find the right Ned for you for
the problems that you think you have but
I'm sure they'll probably tell you you
know you have sort of other problems
that you don't know about so you haven't
been convinced yeah no it's not it's not
we spoke to some great people and I'm
sure at some point we will start so I
mean this the the person that we have as
an interim CMO is effectively an advisor
yeah basically yeah and I think that I
think likelihood is we probably look at
something like that for finance as well
yeah that makes sense and he's not a
recruiter as well that's probably a good
thing yeah it's just different
perspective isn't it so how how are you
both thinking about uh remaining uh I
haven't continuing to have a competitive
advantage in this in this Marketplace
then I'm sure it's something that you
think about like I can only imagine
although obviously it sounds like it's a
real difficult period and it has been
for a while but more and more
recruitment companies are going to be
you know entering the space how do we
feel about uh continuing to have a
competitive advantage of remaining to
have a competitive Advantage how are you
thinking about that
I think yeah I think um we talk about it
a lot we don't talk about it a lot I
think one of the things with crypto
right is that naturally it attracts
people who are like you know pretty
skeptical pretty cynical you know it's
like the whole don't trust verify thing
like part of the technology people kind
of take that approach to to kind of who
they work with as well so I think the
advantage we've got is because we were
you know one of the first people in the
space and we've been around for you know
quite a while I guess we've got a decent
ish moat because of that
um you know it's not just like obviously
the candidate Network and stuff like
that is obviously is obviously helpful
um but I think I think the brand is is
pretty strong I think that that helps a
lot I think there's a lot of tech
recruiters out there who have like tried
to do a little bit of crypto and you
know I'm sure they'll like pick up a few
jobs and stuff like that but I think if
you you know the only way to do the
space is to immerse yourself in it
you've got to like your live and breathe
it every single day
um otherwise the people just a bit
they'll probably just be a bit skeptical
of you so I'm going to ask you where
where we want to be then before we uh
finish and another three to five years
time whatever time Horizon you've been
thinking about but I guess let's just
end on as as we said in preparing for
this someone who's listened to this
right now who is yeah at that 15 Head
Mark really is ambitious to get to that
30 Head Mark but it's finding it
difficult maybe yo-yoing from 20 back to
18 back to 15 whatever Sean I'll come to
you first what what's like the yeah the
one bit of advice or the two bits of
advice that's top of mind for you to
help that founder entrepreneur who's
just really struggling to scale past
that 15 to 20 Head Mark
um you gotta think longer term than
you're perhaps thinking I think a lot of
the time like especially when you're
setting a business up people are just
going to want to try and deal with the
problems in front of their face a lot of
the time and they're probably thinking
about you know like how are we going to
do deals next month and what's our
pipeline like for the next three months
and stuff like that actually you've got
a thing where do I want to be in like
maybe two-ish years something like that
people talk about five-year plans and I
think like that's most of those are just
just dreams basically like if
you're talking about a an actual
strategy an actual plan you know try and
forecast forward maybe a year or two or
something like that think about and then
think about what you need to get there
now and build build the infrastructure
for that now yeah nice to take a step
back and expand the try and do your best
to expand how far ahead you're looking
nice yeah so that's what you've got for
us mate I think like
be comfortable with who you are and like
have a vision for what you want to be
and make sure people feel part of that
so it's not a this is what I want to do
this is what we want to do and this is
why I think we should do it and and I
think
I would also say probably
just because it's an error that we made
like get comfortable with empowering
people in your business because the more
you Empower people the more they will be
loyal because they feel like they are
more part of it than just another person
in that company probably those two
things nice I think what you're saying
about like be proud of like doing in a
certain way that's been absolutely
massive for us like there's a million
different ways to do recruitment there's
lots of different types of companies and
different areas of you know like
recruitment or whatever and they do
things in different ways and they have
different structures and they set up in
different ways and whatever like for us
it was like this is how we do it it
works really well if you don't like it
that's cool don't worry about it we're
not going to change we're going to stick
our flag in this hill and it's it kind
of works for us and actually and that
just that internal kind of branding has
worked really really effectively for us
so I would say do that find out who you
are and just like stick to it basically
so next three years then where are we
going to be let's end on that
let's go
three years this is where you come out
with outrageous statements the next
three years it's going to be what's the
GP goal next three years oh God
I'd like I'd like to get to eight
figures I think I think that's
definitely achievable
um we're moving into this office in the
summer which will hold
maybe 19 maybe 100 people or something
like that which is you know pretty cool
stroke terrifying at the same time
um we really want to do the US
um it's been on the sort of long-term
radar for a while and and got the Visas
and stuff to do that and hopefully next
year we'll get that off the ground and
say I think if we can do that then make
that work and you know make the UK
operation tick over like it has then
yeah I think definitely like uh eight
figures GPS is on the table for sure
that's good yeah yeah 100 I think I
think like we like I I think like the
the the stuff in the states we have to
do it like we've got like a Visa we're
ready to go I think and I think maybe
not even just the states I'd maybe like
to at least be starting to plan maybe
other places in other locations so it's
dictated by the people we've got like if
someone says to me yeah I want to go and
do this and this is what I want to do it
then we start building a plan for that
boy it's been a pleasure yeah see you in
three years mate